Because of scenarios like this, Python provides an extra construct that can be
used as part of the try statement. It's called the Finally clause. And the way
it works is, the code in the Finally Block is guaranteed to always run
regardless of whether the try block finishes, or we go through an exception
handler. So, it could work like this. We could run the try block, if we complete
normally, it will go to the Finally Block, run the finally block, and then we're
done. And note that even if there's something that changes control flow in here,
suppose there's a return and we're inside a function definition. If that's in
the middle of the Block here, normally you would think, well, when we return, we
return, no other code runs. If we've got a Finally, that's not the case. The
Finally code will run before the return happens. If there's an exception before
we get to that, let's say, there's an exception in the try and it goes to the
exception handler, well, that'll run, we're still guaranteed to run the Finally
code. So, this is a construct that leads to lots of complex control flow.
Execution can jump unexpectedly. Well, unexpectedly if you don't know what to
expect. Hopefully, you know what to expect because you've been paying attention.
But execution can jump around in all sorts of strange ways, but it guarantees
that this Finally code, which cleans up if something failed always runs. So,
this almost works. So, we've added our Finally clause and inside the Finally
clause, we're closing the file and because of the semantics of the Finally,
whether we succeed in writing or we go to the exception, we'll eventually run
this close and we only need it in one place. So, this almost works but not
quite. Let me show you what happens. So, I'm going to try running it. And I'm
running it in a directory where the blim.py file is not writable. And here's
what happens. I get the error, so I'm catching the exception, printing Error
writing file, permission is denied, but now, when I try to do fout.close, as you
can see here, I get a name error and I get an error because since the open
didn't succeed, fout was never defined, and we get a name error because the name
fout is not defined.